good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show this monday
morning
in his first broadcast interview since
entering the race to become pm the
chancellor nadeem zahawi says he has
nothing to hide with his tax affairs he
told us he would publish his accounts
annually if he becomes prime minister
there are now 11 candidates in the race
including the foreign secretary liz
tross who also launches her campaign
this morning coming up we'll have that
exclusive interview with mr zahawi and
news of the first televised leadership
debate to be hosted by sky news it's
monday the 11th of july
nadim zahawi tells us why he wants to be
the next prime minister and promises to
be completely open about his tax affairs
even though he doesn't know how rich he
is
i am wealthy you're absolutely right can
you tell us how wealthy you are well i i
don't think it's right to sort of go
into numbers because i'll probably
get it wrong
and then there were 11 candidates to
succeed boris johnson in number 10 and
i'll bring you news of sky news's plans
to host the first televised leadership
debate
protesters in sri lanka say they'll
occupy the president and prime
minister's homes until both leaders
officially resign
the extraordinary occupation follows
months of protest and economic crisis
i'm here at hillington lido in north
west london with parts of the uk hotter
than hawaii and the heat wave set to
continue the met office has issued a
heat health warning
and seven times a charm novak djokovic
reigns supreme at wimbledon once again
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world with boris johnson's
premiership now over i'm going to be
discussing what's next for the uk
relationship with ukraine with their uk
ambassador that's about impristing
and i'll be speaking to the prison
doctor turned author about his new book
documenting stories of life and death
behind bars
[Music]
good morning everybody the contenders in
the race to become pm has now reached
double figures home secretary pretty
patel is also expected to declare later
on today which would bring the total to
12. we'll find out the rules and the
timetable later on today when they're
announced by the 1922 committee of
backbench mps which is in charge of the
contest so far the big issue is tax with
all of the candidates promising cuts
including the chancellor nadim zahawi
who's given his only broadcast interview
to this programme but he said the
country was facing a national emergency
and that would mean many public sector
workers don't receive the pay rises that
they're hoping for
i began by asking him why he wants to be
pm
hi
good to see you thank you for joining us
why do you want to be prime minister
well i think this country um has given
me everything uh i have uh lived the
british dream i came here
at the age of 11 couldn't speak a word
of english um head of the back of the
class okay and of course
very quickly learned to read and um
speak the language but actually think
and then dream in the language
and i want to deliver the opportunity
for every
child in our country every family you
promised when you were education
secretary that teachers would get a nine
percent pay rise that's what you would
be hoping for will they get their money
no your chancellor
so in the manifesto we made a promise
that starting pay for teacher will be 30
000 pounds a year the nine percent
begins to deliver that um and then we
need another seven percent next year to
complete that i pledge that i will do
that that was my submission to the pay
review bodies but but i'm asking more
senior teachers um uh to take uh five
percent over two years uh i'll as
chancellor we'll look at the pay review
bodies from across government and we'll
make a decision together my message to
all public sector workers is look we i
feel your pain but we've got to come
together because if we don't bear down
inflation now
it will hurt us even more in years to
come that's why i think we have to be
fair but firm on fiscal discipline and
get the headroom so that we can then
inject that growth in the economy for
sme small businesses and of course for
people in terms of uh you know their own
taxation so junior nurses can expect
nine percent as well
well i will look at um what the pay
review bodies will
do for
nurses and for the rest of the
public sector and i will with my uh
cabinet colleagues make a decision again
my message is we have to maintain that
discipline and come together in this
really difficult time it is a national
emergency
and if we do this well we'll come out
the other end a lot stronger if we bear
down our inflation and inject that
growth into the economy what services
would you cut
to cut to fund tax cuts so i just
described to you my experience i was the
secretary of state for education yeah
i'm asking you about other departments
so what so what i'm we'll ask every
secretary of state and
the returns should already be in because
boris actually asked all of us to do
this
um i will go through those returns from
each department to see how we can i
managed an education to get close to
that number that the the ask of me
tough
but i could maintain what i needed to do
in terms of what i want to deliver on
skills schools family
and of course um the cross-cutting
issues like recovery from the pandemic
with national
tutoring program
the uh send green paper the but the
health services the health department's
not going to be able to cut their budget
are they so uh
they're just
now under steve barkley i
can tell you there is none better than
steve barkley in being able to focus uh
his uh you know
laser-like focus on
looking at where inefficiencies are and
making sure he delivers those uh cost
savings that the health department uh
i'm certain can do so you think there's
some flab in the health service well
i think it's only right that across
government um
we do this exercise it's an important
exercise it's only right that we
exercise fiscal discipline when it comes
to public sector pay
why because if we do that we can bear
down on inflation that that in itself
brings down inflation so you're saying
20 cotton in every department well
that's what i want to make sure we get
to that will give me the head room to be
able to deliver tax cuts which i want to
deliver okay an emergency budget
i don't think
um i need an emergency budget we are in
the middle of a um
leadership uh campaign there's a
caretaker government at the moment if
things change and i've discussed this
with my perm secretary uh tom scholar uh
then of course i will you know take
whatever action necessary we need to ask
you about your um investigation into
your own uh tax affairs um what was your
reaction when you saw reports that your
own tax affairs were being investigated
by your own department so i was you know
clearly being smeared i was being told
that that the serious ford office that
the national crime industry the hmrc are
looking um into me
i'm not aware
of this i will i've always declared my
taxes i paid my taxes in the uk uh i
will
answer any questions hmrc has uh uh
of me but i will go further okay
i'm going to make a commitment today
that if i am prime minister
i think the right thing to do is to
publish my accounts annually that's the
right thing to do
because i think we need to take this
issue in many ways
off the off the table um i will publish
my accounts annually that's the right
thing to do i will look at you know what
what the options are in terms of back
dating or just publishing annually i
think it's right to do it what about
your tax returns
that's what i'm talking about my taxes
and i'll publish annually okay
over the last decade
well if i'm prime minister i will i will
publish them
um going forward i don't
think being retrospective is right you
know i was in business before i came out
of that of course i'm now in politics is
it true that your family benefits from
an offshore trust
my family does not benefit from an
offshore i don't benefit from an
offshore trust nor does my wife
we don't benefit at all from that
my mother and father live abroad um uh
that's yeah they're their business
they're not they don't live in the
united kingdom have you ever had non-dom
status i've never had non-dom status
have you ever used an offshore company
to avoid tax never use offshore company
how's your family
my family my wife has never been
non-dumb she's never used offshore
status or a company to avoid tax have
you told us everything about your
business affairs that could potentially
impact on your future ability to be
prime minister yes i have have you ever
used offshore companies or services
firms based in tax havens for the
purchase of property or properties in
the uk no
have you fully declared all of your
properties in the mp's register of
interest
yes we have did you pay the requisite
taxes including stamp duty when
purchasing properties yes
uh
you
or your company uh once held 20 million
pounds of hugo shares in a
gibraltar-based company uh what was the
reason for using offshore financial
structures like this if not for the
purpose of avoiding tax i was not the
beneficiary of um
the
balshaw investment that helvos uh shares
um and who was
my family it's the public record um uh
my my father but why would you do that
if it wasn't for the purpose of avoiding
time because he's he lives abroad he
doesn't live in the united kingdom
you are um a very rich man how rich are
you
um
so i've been very lucky i've self-made
um i
have done really well uh by investing in
the united kingdom um and then of course
um my wife uh now continues to invest in
the i can directly in uh you know uk
companies uh back to mark margaret
hodges question um and we we've grown
our investment here um that's i think a
good thing um and it should be
celebrated i am the beneficiary of the
british dream um but i am i am wealthy
you're absolutely right can you tell us
how wealthy you are well i i don't think
it's right to sort of go into numbers
because i will probably
get it wrong
is that because you're so wealthy no
because because these things move around
we've talked about this before but you
did um
claim for heating the stables where the
horses were um you did pay it back um
you said it was a mistake but is that
really the point
it was a mistake because we bought my
wife and i a
cottage
with a riding school
there was a electricity meter in the
riding school there was an electricity
meter in the cottage um
i was
told by the the then chief whip that you
should claim for your uh uh you're
allowed to for your basic running costs
um
it's the right thing to do even if you
don't think um uh you need it um i put
in the claim
genuine mistake not realizing that
actually although there was two meters
um it was coming in on a single bill um
when it became public um there was um a
a an investigative full investigation
into this uh by the parliamentary
authorities they could see it was a
genuine mistake um and they agreed with
me that was a complete error mistake
um and of course i apologized and repaid
it embarrassed of course deeply
embarrassing um but it was a genuine
mistake it's much better to to to you
know admit and
demonstrate um than to do anything else
let's talk about the president's club
uh
it was an event in 2018 in the
dorchester just up the road here
waitresses
female staff said that they were groped
um you were there what did you see
so i was children families minister and
i was invited because this was a charity
that raises over a million pounds for
children's hospital like great ormond
street hospital
i
arrived there
and
just after nine
it was an all-male
black tie due at the dorchester and just
after nine um uh uh young ladies
hostesses um uh that you know came
around each table which made me feel
incredibly uncomfortable which is why i
um
left
the uh dinner
and and went home and
you know
i think in
[Music]
reflection
um
including the charity itself
those sort of you know all-male dinners
are wrong
and i think actually you know one of the
things
that i'm passionate about is that we
treat people properly including people
who are there to serve us um
you know whether
in government or elsewhere and i think
i've got a strong track record whoever
i've worked with
in government
will tell you that i treat people with
respect i treat them properly i engage
with them because we are a team that is
how you deliver your great public
services by working as a team what would
you say to your sons if they were
thinking about going to an event like
that don't go
how would you deal with
chronic sexual misbehavior in the party
i will promise you this
that across government if i am prime
minister i will
bring a an independent um
team they're available in the private
sector they do all the time in in large
organizations that will review
all of our uh practices because a
professional
hr
department in government
is really important and i know the civil
service agrees with me on this
it's really important that we sort of
restore that faith that you know
everyone in the team you know a junior
member of staff um
you know a middle-ranking member staff
can always feel that they work in a
positive environment there should be no
place
for abuse or people feeling threatened
or in some way entering the environment
that's just not quite safe that is just
unacceptable
okay um how important is loyalty to you
given your actions with the prime
minister
over the last week
very important and i think i remained
loyal till the end in fact
when i and many other colleagues went to
see him on wednesday night and i sat
with him i said to him i've known you
for 30 years
you know
you're going to they're going to try and
humiliate you and i can't bear seeing
you being humiliated i want you to to to
just
explain to you what i think is about to
happen
and and i hope you will consider it and
um you know do this with dignity
um who's your hero
my heroine is margaret thatcher i'll
never forget
we arrived here on these shores in 1978
in 79 of course she became a prime
minister my mother saying
a grossest daughter my son has just
become a prime minister in this great
country that has
given us a home and has adopted us you
can do anything in this great country
and
an immigrant boy from baghdad who
couldn't speak a word of english is now
chancellor the exchequer and is
having a uh
a go at trying to become prime minister
this is the greatest country on earth
okay
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed chancellor thank you
well you can watch my full interview
with the chancellor nadeem zaha we're
here on sky news that's at half past
nine huffist eleven and half past two
this afternoon here on sky news an
exclusive interview with the chancellor
on his plans and hopes and dreams to
become prime minister
tomorrow standing by in downing street
for us now morning tomorrow thoughts
morning kay well setting out his stall
there nadeem zaha we are we can see that
tax plans and personal integrity are
going to be crucial issues for all the
candidates in this contest and with that
in mind i can bring you news that next
monday on sky news we will be hosting
the first televised debate of this
conservative leadership contest with the
final candidates remaining in it and it
will be a chance for all of them to set
out their stall to the wider electorate
because although the conservative party
1922 committee will be setting out the
rules for this contest later today what
we broadly expect is several rounds of
voting by mps on the 11 candidates
who've so far announced they want to get
into this race and then the final
decision between the final two will go
out to conservative party members to
make the final decision on our next
prime minister towards the end of next
week so next monday hosted by our very
own kay burley will be the chance for a
wider electorate to see what the
remaining candidates have to offer and
when we asked nadeem zahawi if he would
be willing to take part this is what he
told us
mr hunt mr javid we're hoping we'll
commit to an on-camera debate with us on
sky will you do the same
i would certainly commit to an on-camera
debate
he would jeremy hunt also said he would
be happy to take part and we hope that
all of those remaining in the contest by
next monday will
be able to engage in some of the all the
key issues facing britain in this
leadership contest and of course for the
next prime minister in their entree
okay for now thanks so much tomorrow
thank you so next monday is when that
debate will be taking place um scania is
hosting the first live television debate
with those vying to be the next leader
of the conservative party and the
country's next prime minister monday the
18th of july i'll be hosting the
candidates at the sky news studios in
west london where the contenders will
face questions from a virtual studio
audience the debate will be broadcast
live and for free on sky news channel
501 across sky news digital channels
streamed on youtube and our simulcast to
our irn commercial radio partners
george eustis is here with us now
environment secretary of course i think
i'm right saying you're supporting grant
shaps that's right yes i think he would
take part in our debate i'm sure he
would i mean as you know uh grant shaps
has uh
never been shy in terms of coming out
all the media rounds often on difficult
days in fact one of the reasons i'm
supporting him is firstly i've seen him
in cabinet over the last two years and i
think he's shown a good judgment i've
often been in cobra meetings with him
and we've had
for instance issues around
the short straights and transport and
getting goods into the country and i
think he's always always dealt with
what's thrown his way very very well but
also he's always been willing to go out
and uh back for government on difficult
days when we have those uh difficult
times i've i've always done that he has
too so i'm sure he would take part in
that debate yes why him
over others because i mean it's fair to
say he's not a frontrunner is he well
look i've always taken the view uh in
leadership campaigns and this is the
fourth one that i've seen now that
actually what you should do is uh decide
who you think is the best candidate out
of the field and there are many good
talented candidates they've all got
their strengths but my view is that
grant chaps is the best man to become
our leader and our prime minister at
this particular point he's got cabinet
experience over
several different leaders he's shown
very good judgment uh in my view he's a
very good communicator he did a stint as
party chairman so he's a good campaigner
and we're going to need someone who can
campaign as we go into the next
next general election so i just think
he's got all of the strengths and the
experience that we need at this
particular time and that's why i'm
backing him who else would you fold in
behind
i'm not getting into that i generally
take the view that i pick the candidate
that i think should win and i give it my
all to help them win if something goes
wrong along the way well then i'll
probably uh you know privately decide
what to do at that point but at the
moment
we're talking to lots of people we're
getting lots of interest in his campaign
i think he's only just launched
yesterday but i think he's a very very
strong candidate and i hope that we can
get him that through to that final
run-off for party members looks like
it's already getting ugly
well we tend to get this sort of uh
joshing during any any sort of
leadership campaign as i said the first
one i did was when we got david cameron
elected it was a little bit similar then
but i he came through the field though
didn't he i mean he wasn't a frontrunner
uh that's all right he wasn't a
frontrunner and that's why i don't
believe um any mps should sit on their
hands and wait to see which way the
wind's blowing or declare early because
they think someone's going to win and
they just want to
show their support for who they deem to
be the probable winner it's always the
right thing to do
to make sure that you put your support
behind the candidate that you believe in
and not be shy of coming out publicly
and saying so in the first round and
that's why i'm doing it now for grant
shaps because i think he's the best
candidate i'm not going to sit on my
hands and say well who might win and who
might be in the final round and will he
get support i'm going to get out there
and help him get that support because
i'm confident he's the right person to
do it seems a bit unseemly doesn't it
12.
am i 11 so far probably 12 when pretty
patel um maybe throws a hat into the
ring later on today how are you going to
whittle it down well it is a very wide
field there's no doubt about that and um
the party does have a process for for
whittling it down so there will they
every candidate will need to get you
know a small number of mps to get
nominated and then at home and it used
to be eight i think wasn't it i think it
has been twelve could be thirty well no
it will be for the 1922 committee to
decide the rules i suspect that they
will keep at the numbers for nominations
uh you know reasonably low so that
everybody gets a chance
well i don't know it's not i'm not on
the 1922 committee they'll decide but
but i would have read reports in the
paper that it could be up to 30. you
don't think it'll be that um well i
don't think it should be that because i
think actually what they um what
everyone deserves is a run at the
leadership in the first round whether
they then have a threshold above which
you've got to get in that first round i
think that's a a different matter so we
might see
several candidates locked out in the
first round and then of course the the
exhaustive ballot process as it's called
where you just keep eliminating uh the
final runner and their votes get
redistributed to the next round that can
be done actually very quickly you can
condense that into a few days if you
need to
you do need to we will need to um
because i i think um it's generally
accepted that we should conclude the
parliamentary phases of this uh before
summer recess so that's a week on
wednesday exactly over the next couple
of weeks we want to to get this
concluded and that can absolutely be
done uh through that exhaustive ballot
process you you can hold several ballots
in in one day if you want to so the 1922
committee uh and to graham brady will
obviously be working out what the rules
should be but i absolutely think yes
it's uh it's doable it's a tight
timetable uh it means people have a
short period of time to make their case
uh but i'm here today to make that case
for grant chaps okay um it just seemed
with all of the runners and riders that
there was an awful lot of pent up
frustration as far as this prime
minister is concerned all of these
people now wanting his job why did you
stick by him
look i didn't campaign for boris johnson
in the last uh leadership campaign in
2019 i campaigned as you might remember
for michael gove at that time
and i i thought i knew all of um boris
johnson's strengths and his weaknesses
and when he offered me a place in his
government i've always thought it's
really important that when the party
makes a decision on a leader that you
all rally around and you pull back
together and you work as a team and
that's what i've done and so i
worked and showed support for the
government the conservative government
to deliver our agenda indeed that is
what
every other cabinet minister also did
yes all of them would have had some of
the differences with the prime minister
all of them would have had things they
wanted done slightly differently but we
were all working as a team to deliver
for that conservative manifesting sure
but if they hadn't had the nerve people
like setting javid
and rishi sunak to break ranks we would
still have the prime minister imposed
well i think it was coming to a head
because almost certainly
the party was heading for another
confidence vote in the prime minister
probably would have happened this week
and actually probably would have
happened even if no one uh had resigned
and he probably would have lost at that
point so i think um it came
to the to a point where cabinet members
even those like me who were loyal to him
even grant shaps who were loyal to the
government and wanted us to hold
together we all realized uh at that
point that he just had lost the
confidence of the party and then you
couldn't carry on prime ministers are
not directly elected it's not a
presidential system uh they they exist
and they're there uh you know only while
they have the support of parliament in
general and in particular of course uh
the vast majority of mps on their own
benches because prime ministers can't
get anything done without that and i
think once it was clear that he no
longer had that um many cabinet
ministers spoke to him or spoke to his
team or spoke to the chief whip to say
uh you know that that the time is up
he's going to have to resign and i'm
pleased that's what he did you know he
reflected on that advice that he had
from cabinet ministers and chose to step
down on his own terms when will we know
who the next prime minister is
um it will probably
be i would imagine sometime in september
the 1922 committee and the conservative
party will obviously need to announce
the rules but they'll be the
parliamentary rounds over the next two
weeks so we'll be down to probably just
two candidates uh by the end of next
week and then those two candidates will
go out on a series of hustings around
the country during august possibly early
september as well i would imagine at
some time uh you know middle of
september perhaps we'll have a new
leader in place yeah after they've
ripped lumps out of each other let's see
what happens good to talk to you well
it's very important that people you know
we're all colleagues and we're going to
have to pull back together and work
together very important people people
work sensibly okay for now thanks very
much indeed thank you a quick look at
what the papers are saying the telegraph
leading with the breaking news that the
foreign secretary liz tross has joined
the conservative leadership battle the
times says the home secretary pretty
patel is about to join in the fight as
they canvass the support of uh the right
wing against rishi sunak
the eye leads with a prediction that the
final runoff will be between mr sunak
and one of the other candidates who
declared so far
more talk of smears in the express with
the new chancellor and leadership
contender nadim zahawi claiming he's
being smeared over his personal tax
affairs
meanwhile the financial times says that
the senior party figures running the
election after planning to thin out the
field of candidates more quickly by
raising the number of mps they each need
to support their nomination
still to come on the programme more
reaction to the prime minister's
resignation speaking to the former head
of the civil service lord butler about
what boris johnson's departure means for
those in whitehall
and with 11 contenders now in the
running i'll be joined by the former
conservative mp neil parish to discuss
their chances and his controversial
departure from the party
[Music]
under the government's agenda now at a
standstill i'll be talking to a red wall
mayor about why leveling up should be a
priority whoever the next prime minister
might be
to sri lanka now where protesters say
they'll continue to occupy the
residences of the president and the
prime minister until both men keep their
word and leave office they agreed to
resign after thousands of people stormed
government buildings in colombo
nicole is standing by for us now in
colombo hi nicole what's the latest
where you are
well we are inside the president's house
that was stormed on
saturday and you can see crowds of
people are coming and it's actually
quite orderly but all over this building
there are thousands of sri lankans
taking the opportunity to see the real
seat of power because what's happened
here over the last couple of days is
extraordinary it could lead to a sort of
seismic shift with the rajapaksa
political dynasty out and that's what
all of these people want that's what
they're demanding they say they've had
enough of the severe economic crisis
that has gripped this country for the
last few months they blame the roger
puckses they say that they spent all the
country's money and now sri lanka can't
afford to import food
fuel or medicine
so ever since those massive
demonstrations that we saw on saturday
people have been uh coming to the
president's house they've been trying to
check out
the opulence and the luxury of how the
other half have been living while
they've been struggling
unable to eat three times a day people
are saying that they won't leave that
they will continue
this demonstration and occupying the
buildings
for as long as the president and the
prime minister remain in power
okay thank you
now you may have noticed over the
weekend but it's been rather hot and it
looks set to continue with the met
office and the uk health security agency
putting out a level 2 heat health alert
warning in parts of the east and the
south of the country
maddie standing by for us at lido or is
it a lido in north west london for us
this morning hi good morning cooling
down in the pool already lovely
morning kay yes it is isn't it and it is
a really scorching start to the week the
temperature is forecast to reach 33
degrees today that would be the hottest
day of the year but it also will be even
hotter here than it is in the bahamas or
the maldives so um that is lovely if you
can cool down at a lido but obviously it
does make it very hard for people to
stay cool especially at night and get to
sleep that is why um the met office has
issued this heat health warning and it
advising it is advising people to cover
or shade their windows and to check in
with vulnerable or elderly people as
well um so if you can stay cool and
enjoy the heatwave which is set to last
all week do but don't forget your sun
cream
okay for now thank you
look at our top stories for you this
morning on the breakfast show monday
morning sky news speaking exclusively to
this program the chancellor nadim zahawi
has promised to be completely open about
his tax affairs insisting that he or his
wife have never been non-dom and have
always paid their taxes that are due in
the uk
foreign secretary has launched her bid
to become the next prime minister bowing
to cut taxes from day one
and now 11 candidates in the race to
become conservative leader with the
timetable for the contest due to be
announced today by the backbench 1922
committee sky news has announced plans
to host the first of the televised
leaders debates next monday
returning now to our exclusive interview
with the chancellor nadeem zahari mr
zahari dismissed allegations that he's
being investigated by his own department
over his tax affairs as a smear he also
told me if he were to become prime
minister he would publish his tax
records in full each year
so i was
clearly being smeared i was being told
that that the serious ford office that
the national crime industry the hmrc are
looking um into me
i'm not aware
of this i will i've always declared my
taxes i paid my taxes in the uk uh i
will
answer any questions hmrc has
of me but i will go further okay
i'm going to make a commitment today
that if i am prime minister
i think the right thing to do is to
publish my accounts annually
and he's subsequently um gone further
than that to say that if he becomes uh
one of the final two in the contest to
become prime minister then he will also
uh put forward his accounts uh to be
scrutinized so let's see what happens as
far as that's concerned meantime no
secret that mr zahawi is a very rich man
but i was interested to know just how
rich he is here's what he told me
i've been very lucky i've self-made
i
have done really well uh by investing in
the united kingdom um and then of course
um my wife uh now continues to invest in
the united kingdom directly in uh you
know uk companies
uh back to mark margaret hodges question
um
and we we've grown
our investment here um that's i think a
good thing um and it should be
celebrated i am the beneficiary of the
british dream um but i am i am wealthy
you're absolutely right can you tell us
how wealthy you are well i i don't think
it's right to sort of go into numbers
because i will probably you know get it
wrong
tomorrow standing by down the street for
us morning tomorrow
morning kay well the candidates all
setting out their stalls now and we can
see how tax cuts or whether or not they
will have them how far they will go is
going to be a crucial issue in this
contest as well as personal integrity
given what happened with boris johnson
in the final days and weeks nadim zahawi
trying to bust some of the allegations
which will likely be leveled at him over
his own personal taxes and some of his
own personal record as he is seen as one
of the key candidates in this contest
there are now 11 who have declared they
want to run liz trust the latest to
throw her hat into the ring last night
the foreign secretary saying she would
implement tax cuts including reversing
the rise in national insurance from day
one if she becomes prime minister also a
hell of a lot of mudslinging as well
between the different candidates and
some really interesting alliances who is
backing who we'll get tonight the
timetable for this contest and we expect
there will be rounds of voting by
conservative mps to whittle it down to
the final two candidates and they want
to do that by next thursday which is
when mps go off for their summer recess
so it's going to really be a breakneck
pace with potentially rounds of voting
every day and we'll also get the
announcement of how many nominations
candidates will need in order to join
the race with
a feeling among those i've spoken to
close to the 1922 committee that they
want to make it a relatively high bar
you'll remember in 2019 mps only needed
eight nominations to run in the contest
this time it's expected to be at least
20 if not a bit higher than that in
order um to try and whittle down some of
the lesser-known candidates who have
said they are entering the race so
tonight we'll get the timetable and over
the next 10 days we'll get a clear sense
of where this contest is going in terms
of the final two who will be voted on by
conservative party members and of course
our sky news televised debate next
monday could be a big moment of the
contest okay tamara thank you well the
1922 committee of conservative back
benches sets the rules of the party and
is electing new members today as we
heard all 18 places on the executive
will be up for grabs let's just take a
look at the timetable of the day for you
the group's executive has 18 members as
i said with six officers including the
chair which is uh gray and brady sir
graham brady later tonight we'll find
out who's in and who's out
the new exec will then set out the rules
and timetable for the leadership
competition it's likely mps will whittle
the list down to two over the next 10
days or so members will then vote over
the summer before a successor is named
potentially before parliament returns in
early september let's get more reaction
now to the resignation of the prime
minister and indeed what it will mean
for civil servants working in whitehall
joining us now is the former head of the
home civil service that's lord butler
hello my lord thank you so much for
joining us good morning how tricky is it
for civil servants when we have a sort
of
cat i'm being told not to call him a
caretaker prime minister but that's what
he is
well the job of the civil service is to
keep the show on the road and so it's
not really very tricky and it's not a
very long period um so um
during the next 10 days it is while
parliament's sitting and until it's
whittled down to the last two
there shouldn't be any major decisions
to be taken and major decisions
shouldn't be taken
and then during
the period when the conservative party
is consulting in the country then
there's really only two candidates and
they can be consulted on any major
decisions that have to be taken
what about when we saw um ministers
dropping like flies last week were there
enough ministers 25 had gone from the
prime minister's government not enough
to run the country we were told no
absolutely not um and so a lot of
business couldn't go on there weren't
people to attend parliamentary
committees and so things
virtually ground to a stop
but again um there wasn't an awful lot
to do parliament goes into recess in the
summer and so you know you can operate
for quite a long time without all the
politicians being in place
as far as civil servants are concerned i
spoke to i don't know if you managed to
catch our interview it'll be online as
well with the present chancellor he was
saying that he had successfully managed
to cut 20 from the budget of uh the
running costs of the department of
education he wants to do that across the
whole of government in order to have
enough money for tax cuts um that would
mean job losses for civil servants
surely yes i i expect it would um and
well when i was um private secretary to
margaret thatcher the civil service was
cut by a hundred thousand now it's not
impossible to do that
the question is how it's done and it
ought to be done with respect and with
care for the people who you're employing
um we did hear the prime minister um
talk about the peerless british civil
service when he made his speech that
we'll call a resignation speech last
week but he once tried to cut what
ninety or thousand jobs in the
civil service over the cost of living
crisis um
how important is it
to have a prime minister that is um duly
respectful of the staff around him well
it's very important um i always think of
gerald ratner you remember i do very
much and you don't get give leadership
you don't get loyalty you don't get
results
if you don't treat your employees with
respect
when we talk about the civil service um
people at home this morning getting
ready for work were thinking what does
the civil service actually do and the
answer is you know that all sorts of
things they don't just work in offices
in whitehall here do they they work in
prisons they work all over the place yes
and it's their job to support the
government of the day to support its
policies and to carry them out as
efficiently as they can
and they are roles that are um
non-political that must be quite tricky
on occasion well of course i mean
government is about politics but you
mustn't take a partisan view so what
civil servants have to do is to work for
the government that the electors
produce
and how difficult is the transition not
only from when you have one prime
minister of the same colour to another
one
you know whoever the next conservative
prime minister will be but also when you
have a complete change of regime well it
can be a bit of a personal trauma yes
i'm sure so tell me more about that yeah
well you get very close to the person
you're working with i got very close to
john major and then tony blair came in
and then you just have to demonstrate
that you are going to do your best for
the new incumbent as professionally as
you can and you can usually build up
confidence about that quite quickly
this period you say it is a period of
transition but it's fairly
straightforward you think as far as the
civil servants are concerned are you
saying that it's just basically a
holding pattern they're marking time
what if the present prime minister
decides that he does want to push
through some major policy i don't know
on the northern ireland protocol while
this process is going through well it's
not a very long time
six weeks
about six weeks maybe well six weeks but
only um ten days probably until we're
the last down to the last two
candidates and the prime minister
shouldn't do that he'd be advised not to
do that by whom by or by the head of the
civil service by the cabinet secretary
not least and ministers would be advised
in a similar way by the permanent
secretaries in their departments and i
would expect them to comply with that
and as far as just before i let you go
because i know you're terribly busy um
when we've seen what's been happening in
downing street over a period of time
during lockdown how much did you feel
for those civil servants that were
working there at the time
oh i i felt for them very acutely i mean
i think for everybody the covid was a
very difficult time and they were
working extremely hard but i was also
ashamed of some of the behavior that
went on in 10 downing street it
shouldn't have happened i don't believe
it would have happened when i was
working there because we had such
respect for
the institution for the government we
felt privileged to be there we felt
respect for the prime ministers who we
served
and the way sue gray was treated
well i think sue gray was put in a very
difficult position i don't think you
know a civil servant can ever really be
asked to um
a judge on the behavior of
their boss
and so sue gray produced the facts it
wasn't for her to produce a judgment i
think she handled it very well in a very
difficult situation and if the same
situation or similar situation were to
develop again you don't think that it
would be for a civil servant to be find
themselves in that position so who who
should um judge on the prime minister's
behavior it has to be the cabinet
parliament and eventually the electorate
well let's see what happens good to talk
to you my lord thank you so much for
joining us much appreciated thank you
let's get more now on the prospects of
the eleven so far eleven conservative
party leader hopefuls joined by the
former conservative mp for tibetan and
honeton that's neil parish hello to mr
parrish good morning good morning nice
to come on thank you oh good thank you
for joining us what are your thoughts on
the fact that it's a pretty uh crowded
field already
it is and of course you know it was a
fairly bloody end to the prime minister
it was necessary but of course it's not
only about the candidates now bringing
the party back together as well and also
making sure you know as we're you know
getting a new leader that we're still
running the country with the cost of
living crisis and the situation in
ukraine so it's a it's a we really need
to get on with it and i think that's why
you know the rules that bring in 20 at
least backers for the first round then
probably 35 after that i think you know
whittled down very quickly you've got
some interesting candidates out there
because you've got them sort of main
runners if you like like rishi and
savage um perhaps liz truss um but
you've got people like penny mordent and
and also uh people like tom tuggenheart
and um you know
baden knock is a is an interesting sort
of very straightforward lady and then of
course you've got celebrant who is very
much perhaps the the champion of some of
the the big brexiteers and of course
it's interesting in the party to see you
know is it brexit is it remain i think
we gotta perhaps get over that and and
get on um with delivering brexit and
running the country so it's a it's a
great challenge for everybody and in the
meantime you know i can say this now i'm
not there we've got to stop really
taking chunks out of each other like
we've been doing that for too long
do you think it's appropriate that the
prime minister stays on as a caretaker
prime minister in the interim or do you
think that dominic rob should have
stepped up
i think as long as he doesn't try to say
you know big policy decisions go you
know spending commitments and the like
and we can get it done by we when
members of parliament came back in
september so you see two weeks time
parliament will recess and there needs
to be a government in place but there
will be no you know legislation going
through parliament i think by the time
we get back in september we will need a
new elected you know by the party prime
minister i think it it also does need to
go to party members because the trouble
is you can have what you call a
coronation you know like happened with
theresa may when you just the
parliamentary party decides the second
candidate withdraws and you have a prime
minister immediately that might be quite
you know successful in some way for
government but of course the problem is
the party is very you know is very
perhaps divided over the situation uh
with boris johnson um they will want now
to have their say
and i think it's time you know that the
country saw you know through hustings
and others the the the two that come
through very strongly i mean i i
personally think um rishi sunak is is a
very powerful um
candidate i mean he came under the slack
committee that i chaired in in um in 16
i said to my wife he's a very bright man
he'll go far little did i know you know
for four years time he'd be chance for
the exchequer but you know there's a lot
a lot of arguing going on at the moment
you know people a lot a lot of the the
you know
savvy david and others want to bring in
you know a lot of tax cuts but of course
we're still borrowing a huge amount of
money every month to balance the books
you know are you if you're going to make
tax cuts are you going to cut public
spending all sorts of things i think you
know i think we have to be quite
truthful the candidates not only to the
party uh but to the country because you
know with the situation boris had many
strengths as prime minister but his
weakness there i say it was actually
coming out with the whole truth and i
think people actually want somebody to
step up to the market say this is what a
government we want to bring in this is
where you can trust us and you know
there will be some tough times because
the economy you know british people we
can get out of this
the economy is tough at the moment
to what extent um do you have to accept
some responsibility for hit your
indiscretion for his downfall
i you know i mean what i did you see my
indiscretions were very wrong uh and and
i decided to resign now what that
created was a by-election i don't think
i brought down his downfall i think it
what what happened was once a
by-election was called of course it also
was a big run of events where you know
you had all sorts of things coming out
about the situation over partygate and
then you had your ethics advisor going
all sorts of things happened during the
by-election so in the end it became very
much a referendum um over
the situation uh to do with boris but
then of course then of course coupled
with that you have had the pincher
episode which was just a classic boris
you know where first of all you're
supporting the man he shouldn't have
ever been there being deputy chief whip
but of course eventually you know did he
know didn't he know and it all got
dragged out of a period of another four
or five days a minute secretaries of
state had to go out and try and defend
him only for number 10 then to come out
you know a few hours later and have to
admit more and more and more and of
course it you know i i've said this
before you know i sat at least six times
in committee room 14 in the past where
inbounds is boris and said it'll all be
better you see but of course it can't be
better because because bless him
although he's good on a lot of the big
issues and and i hope he does get a a
big role in in ukraine because i think
he's done a perfectly good job there but
you know he had to go i'm afraid um and
i don't think i brought about his
downfall but it was all
but you have to yeah i mean you know
you've obviously lost your position and
that's not great for for you or your
family and the embarrassment that was
caused but you have to accept you know
some uh responsibility don't you for
your indiscretions
yeah i do and and you know i apologize
again for what i did but i think i don't
think i think my my with my what
happened to me and what the by-election
was sort of part of the process that
brought the downfall of of the prime
minister it didn't actually cause it and
i think i still did the right thing um
and i think you know christopher pincher
ought to consider his position as well
i'm afraid because i think you know if
you have done something that's really
wrong i think you have got to face up to
your responsibilities and go i mean it's
been naturally quite traumatic for
myself my family but i i created the
mess i decided to make the right
decision so that's how it stands
did you manage to buy your new tractor
after all
yeah i'm getting yes i've got to do a
new tractor and um i'm also sort of
building up my farming side of it
because um naturally i go back to my my
roots which are very deep in farming but
i still have a have a political brain
you see so hence i'm on here this
morning to perhaps try and give a sort
of fairly candid view on where the party
is and where all the candidates are well
we love the opportunity to talk to you
please come back again because i'm sure
there's an awful lot of more chatting to
do between now and when we find out who
the next prime minister is thank you for
taking the time to join us this morning
thank you very much thank you thank you
well boris johnson's resignation has
cast out over what aspects of his
government's agenda will live on and now
one mayor has called on conservative mps
vying to be the party's next party
leader and prime minister to fully
commit to levelling up in red wall and
left behind areas joining us now t is
rally mayor that's been hutchinson hello
to mr hajj and thanks for joining us on
the programme what do you want to hear
from these candidates
well this morning i've written to the
leadership contenders because we're
talking a lot about tax cuts there's
obviously an internal battle within the
conservative party for the next leader
but what we're not hearing is what
they're going to do and whether they're
going to recommit to leveling up that
was a key policy of the boris johnson
government it's one of the things that
led to many people voting conservative
for the first time ever
it obviously started to build what is
that that trendy term the red wall and
i've asked that there are a minimum
number of principles that these
leadership contenders sign up to to make
sure that this fantastic policy and
something that's actually really needed
to bring the rest of the uk together
that they they sign up to these minimum
number of principles actually like i say
is a minimum i hope they can go further
and develop a very strong leveling up
policy but at the moment we're not
hearing anything from any of the
contenders and i would hope that mps
before they vote on wednesday we'll be
asking these questions because there are
many of those mps that have their seat
because of the level of policy that
boris johnson championed
who are you looking at who's taking you
fancy at the moment
well at the moment nobody's replied to
the letter and my concern at the minute
is making sure that largely the north
but also other parts of left behind
areas across the country are fully
supported i think the leveling of gender
is agenda is absolutely key to achieving
that and i'll be deciding on who i
support depending on the responses and
who gives the uh the best responses to
develop that policy and taking like i
say areas like mine in t-side have been
left behind for many many decades what
is a new prime minister going to do to
be able to support an area like ours not
just t side but across the whole of the
north of england and as i said when
there was this whole debacle going on
about whether we should get rid of
the prime minister boris johnson or not
my concern is this agenda could be on
the back burner and like i said over the
last few days all we've heard about is
tax cuts and they're extremely important
and i'm sure that people will make their
mind up about that but there is much
more to running a government than just
tax cuts and i think the leveling up
agenda is something that will define the
next general election
i'm guessing you also want the final two
candidates to come up to the region and
talk to the local people there
absolutely um and i agree with many
people who said that what we actually
need to make sure is that this isn't
just the coronation what we can't have
is a stitch up between the final two
candidates and then the members and the
wider um the wider country can't see
what the two candidates have to offer
and as we did when boris johnson was
selected as prime minister there should
be a number of hustings across the
country people should be able to form
their views before deciding on who the
new prime minister is going to be
okay um just do you prime minister
should the new prime minister be a
northerner
um i'm less concerned about where
they're from i mean prime minister boris
johnson is not from the north of england
but is arguably one of the biggest
champions of the north of england for
many many decades it depends on the
policy of the person like i say that in
the letter that i've written i want to
see people uh i want to see sorry the
contender uh who is successful commit to
keeping a secretary of state responsible
for levelling up i want to see them uh
commit to more devolution for other
parts of uh england and potentially
parts of the uk as well because it's
been hugely successful in places like
t-side i want more powers to existing
mayors i would say that would not being
a mayor
in england i also want the government to
commit to really important
uh
large infrastructure projects which i
think send a huge statement to
communities and the public across the uk
like northern powerhouse rail i think we
need to go further and we need to get
eastwood's connectivity across the north
as being much much stronger um so
there's a huge amount that needs to be
done um and i hope that whoever is
successful commits to that agenda that's
going to be largely deciding where my
support goes and whether they come from
oxford whether they come from central
london or whether they come from
middlesbrough it doesn't matter as long
as they've got the right policies for
the country
um just before i let you go we're almost
out of time if boris johnson could stand
again
would you vote for him
i'm hugely sad and disappointed that
this prime minister's going i've always
been a huge supporter it's no
um it's no there's no way from getting
away from that um i think he's done a
huge amount for the north of england i
think he's starting a really interesting
agenda i think he's attracted people to
politics and to vote for the
conservatives that would never have
considered voting for us before and it's
fair to say that under this prime
minister my area that i represent has
done extremely well so it's a sad day um
when i see this prime minister go and
hopefully um the next prime minister
will be able to do as much as they can
to fill his boots and you know that's
yet to be seen
okay great to talk to you thanks so much
indeed thank you been chatting to the
chancellor uh in an exclusive broadcast
interview here on sky news you can
listen to it in more detail at half past
nine this morning when we'll run it in
full but uh the headlines include
allegations
of his non-dom status i said to him have
you ever had non-dom status i've never
had non-dom status he said
have you ever had offshore companies to
avoid tax i've never used an offshore
company to avoid tax has your family i
asked him my family my wife has never
had non-dom status have you told us
everything about your business affairs
that could potentially impact on your
future ability to be prime minister yes
i have he said and he went further than
that he said that if he finds himself in
the final two in the contest to be the
next prime minister conservative prime
minister then he would publish his
accounts showing his tax affairs and
implications
um he did also though tell us that he
wasn't sure how rich he was not sure how
that's going to go down with some of
those uh watching this morning
especially given a cost of living crisis
but
there you go he this is mr zahawi
arriving at the
treasury
on the first morning of his new post
will he be arriving at number 10 before
too long he and 11 others fancy it stay
tuned and find out more
[Music]